abone ol
e
[Alkış]
herkese selamlar hiç hazırlık yapmadım
ben gelişigüzel
hissettiklerimi söyleyeceğim Çünkü yeni
nesille ilgili çok fazla iş yapıyorum
aynı zamanda diye akademim var yeni
nesil olarak çok fazla bir arada o vakit
geçiriyorum
hocaları bahsettiği psikolojik Oha izler
bir sürü kitap okudum ama biz de çok
daha bittiğini görmedim
yazdığı
kitap
Türkiye'de yaşayan bir çok fazla
bizim diyeceğim öğrencilere aynı zamanda
ile ilgili
öz güven vermeli
ne
dersen de Açmaya başlıyoruz yeni size
konuşuruz bir şey söyleyeceğim
aldığım Siz gerçekten su ki Allah
kendine işlerin yanında hayal kurarken
bir şey yapmayı çok seviyorum işte
olmak üzere sizlerden benim
ay ettiği şerefiniz yere giderken bunun
için bir şeyler yaparsanız
[Müzik]
çok çalışırsanız bizi geleceksiniz şimdi
kendine bahsedeceğim
hayatı -15 başlamış gibi Anadolu ıssız
bir şey olur yapmak sizi Saydım
hayallerimiz var ve Kayseri'de misiniz
Bunlar gerçekten ben Diyarbakır'da
doğdum ve en son iki ay önce İspanyol
Kraliyet ailesinde Kraliyet sarayında
müzik çalıyor ben de kendimi çok
geliştirdim
ve Ecrin ve genç arkadaşlarım var içinde
DJ olmak isteyen var mı Mesela
İstanbul'da olanlar için bir evimiz var
şu an ülkenin birçok yerinde dünyanın
çok iyi bir müzik çalan bir şeyler var
çok zor bir yolcu DJ'lik başlı başına
kendimiz yapacağımızı anlatmanın olmamız
gereken bir şey yalan jip
asla iyi ona
normal vuruyorum işte Mesela mı Bu
fotoğraflar getiriliyor gece kulüpleri
olduğu için
Sonuçta bir arayıp fotoğraf video
getirmedim sosyal medyadan takip
edebilirsiniz
çok değerli kıymetli hocalar var Onların
da önemli fikirleri var bende
motivasyon konuşmalarını izliyorum T3
ile tanışmam çok ilginç Bu şarkı
yaparken Elif hakkı olmayan vokaller
ararken
motivasyon sözleri çok karışma sesler
var biz aldık işte
önemli
çok fazla Çünkü burada birkaç tane
kendini geliştirme ilgili konferans
[Müzik]
ulaşamadım da
değil zaten
Aile Geniş ama yaptığım bir şey olabilir
büyük aileler bir destek olalım Hatta
büyüklerimin çağırır yazarak bizim
aileden işte terörist çıkmadı O çıkmadı
buçuk sen varsın Ne yapıyorsun
annem zaten o
ne vardı çok ama olsun Kes yapıyorum
konuşma yüzünden senin Size arkadaş
benim
çok nasıl şeyler
iyice yapılanmasıyla tavsiye
edebileceğim kendi öğrencilerin
mesleki
yabancı dil i
iyi olman lazım diye düşündüğüm için
bugün buradayım benim için İlk oldu
Kayseri daha önce gelmemiştim niye
gelmediğini düşünce gece tüm olduğu yere
istediğiniz yerde aynı
Eskişehir de
[Müzik]
çok acayip güzel bir şey yapacağınız işe
giderken verin paylaşımcı oldu Kendinize
iyi Yabancıyız yoksa cozum vardır Onu
öğrenip psikolojinizi ilk bak olduğuna
benim size önerebileceğim asıl değil
konuşmamın amacım hepsi çok ciddi
hedefler koymuş ailelerinin çok Bu
konuyla ilgili baskı yaptığı
insanlarsınız zor coğrafyada yaşıyoruz
zaten
sanatın olmadığı coğrafya ne
yapıyorsanız yapın yani sabahla ilgili
herhangi bir şey oluyor Görsel olur
işitsel olur ya farklı bir dünya
görüşürüz vardı ilahi dinleyin Mesela
işte daha Sucu Bir yaklaşımımız vardır
Osmanlı dönemleri sanatlarla uğraşan
yani Turkey bir sanatla uğraşır
yardımıyla elektronik bisikleti ile
uğraşmak zorunda değilsiniz
DJ akademide annemin ilk iki haftasında
e Okul olduğu için kapatırız dedi
herhalde Çünkü işe gelmez bir ara
telefonda olan cayır istiyorsun Genel
Müdürü
başarının böyle Elif noktasında
kişilerin şeyi çekip şeyi çeşitli işler
kendim için bir şey yapmadıklarını işte
Herkes diyecek olmak istiyorum müzikle
ilgili bir şeyler öğrenmek istiyorum Biz
boyunca bana gönder önceki yoğunluktaki
yaşadım
o yüzden yapacağımız işi
kalitesine Psikolojimizi özellikle böyle
birşey müzikle ilgili
geldiğinde
ses sistemi ile geliyor şarkılarıyla
çalarım birşey oldu şarkılarımı
biliyorsunuz yıllarca bu işte Yıldız
Tilbe ile tanışmak Herkesin hayatı ver
mesela o birlikte etmek için bana Pizza
ısmarlıyorum işi yapıyorum merak ettiğim
kişileri çok çalışalım kendimi işleyerek
ve size önerdim ikinci konuda sevdiğiniz
şey yapmaya bakın sevgili şey yapınca
başarılı olursunuz ver bize odaklandım
stüdyonun kurduk 715 illerden yardım
Diyarbakır'dan geldim diyecek canım
gitmem gerektiğinin farkındaydım varmış
gittim indireceğim çok iyi ama lisesi
İstanbul değerleri kendi çok değişmem
İstanbul'da mı
ne var ya Başka parka kurdu Onunla
beraber takip edenler varsa yurt dışı
işler yapıyor bir başka kendine göre
başarılı kayma Bu nasıl oldu kendi
gibi oraya giderken bir
şeyi sosyal medya kullanıyor musun param
var mı hayır çevrem vardı
bütün
kullanmanız gereken bir dönem
sizlerin bence hani ben geldim dediğim
zaman internet yoktu şu an internette
istediğiniz her şeyi bulabileceğiniz
diğer ve bol
olması hepsi bir koku Herkes bir şeyler
var mı
ne güzel ne doğru mesleğinizde giderken
birkaç şey var işte Derslerle ilgili
yapacağım her şeyi biliyorsunuz O benim
haddime değil söyleyeceğim söyleyemem
ama bir sanatlarını hayatınızda sokup
kesinlikle başladığımız olsun biliyorsan
ikinci İspanyolca dersleri başladı
eşyaları da cinsiyet yok olduğunu
öğrenince bıraktım İspanyol olacak Çok
zor Çünkü ben biliyorum onu öğrenirim
dedim olmuyormuş öyle Şimdi başka bir de
başlayacağım
ekip oğlu insanlara verin bir arada olur
Ben şu anda yanımda 10 kişi çalışıyor
hepsine bütün tecrübelerimi anlatıyorum
vermekten sırlarımı meslek isimleri
görmekten çekiniyorum verirken öğreniyor
bizim toplum olarak zaten
birşeyleri kapatma saklama o duymasını
benden önce olmasın sözü ne yazık ki
benim annem de bakalım bunları sen
biliyorsun falan söyleme seni geçerler
diyordu geçti
Evet
ben canım da yarışırız şimdi Çünkü
gerçekten arkamda herhangi bir şey
olmadan yaptım bazı şeyleri ve her doğum
gününden bir gün önce oturup 365 gün
önce Neredeydin şimdi ne yaptım diye
kendinle yarış küçücük Özellikle bizim
meslekte hiç ummadığınız insanlar çok
büyük başarılar gösteriyor onları
Kıskanma ile ben yollamadım var zaman
geçirelim psikoloji Bozar Böyle olmak
istemiyorum Sizler de hiç ailede baskı
yapsa etrafınızdaki birleşik olarak
görmek Tabii ki ve tabletle kendinize
rakip olup kendimizi psikolojinizi
özellikle diyorum müzik
uğraşır mı
[Müzik]
ben sana Ben
2014'te hayal etti İşte Bodrum'un İsim
vermiyor dünyanın en büyük bir başına
gelecek
DJ
dönemi önemli anlaşmalar yaptık
özellikler şirketleriyle önce annemin
[Müzik]
yaşadığı kötü şeylere
Sahip olduğunuz ve yendiğimiz O da
tavsiye yere taşır Bunun yanına
dersimizin yanında o yüzden sabahla
ilgili bir şey koyu konuda kendime
eğitirseniz bugün çok işinize yarayacağı
göreceksiniz
benim söyleyeceklerim çok fazla değil
bıraksanız bir saat konuşurum ama ciddi
olması lazım
savcılar bütün dünyada
telefon Nerde çalışıyor Benimki de
soralım
Kendimden bir şey yapamıyoruz
sevgiler para biriminiz ilgis arkadaşlar
70 yapın
şarkıları o kadar karşılaşırsak
söyleyeceğim
Şu
anda
çalışma markanın kendi
sağlığı için mi
bu Bulacağımı kaybetti artık daha
yemişler onlarla işler yapmak tercih
ediyoruz üzerinde yapmak istediğiniz
şeyler de kendimizden bir şeyler
atabileceğiniz
şeyleri izin verecek ortamda olmaya Özen
gösterin o zaman farklı yapıyorsunuz
kendiniz oldu fare çok zor
çok zor
ne kadar
onlardan daha çok çalışmamız gerektiğini
anlayacaksınız ama mesleki ama
başarırsanız
korkmayın sizi Müslüman ve ortadoğu diye
yargılanıyorlar dünya insanın içinde iyi
mi oğlum ay arıyorlar Ben şu anda
İtalyan Yunan ekiplerde çalışıyorum ve
şimdi İspanyollarla başladım çok
korkuyorum da
Müslüman değerlerine ortada olduğu
değerlerle çok korkuyorduk Hiçbiri
olmadı sizleri de yolu açık ne olur yurt
içinde Defol yurt dışında bir şeyler
yapamıyorsun da insanlarla tanışıp
Sizlerle olmak çok güzel güzel
organizasyon için Herkese teşekkür
ediyorum Benden bu kadar görüşmek üzere
[Alkış]